Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar, and you're watching Mind Your Decisions.
Consider a rectangular array of circles.
We'll fill in some of these circles to make a mathematical expression.
It currently reads (10 + 11)(10 - 11) = 100 + 1!.
But this is not currently a valid equation.
The challenge is to color four blue dots,
or erase four blue dots to make a valid equation.
I thank Professor Peer Johannsen at Pforzheim University for creating this puzzle
Can YOU figure it out?
Give this problem a try and when you are ready keep watching the video for a solution.
So, how can we make this into a valid equation?
The amazing answer is that we're going to make each eleven into a 1 times i.
We need to erase a total of 4 dots.
In each of the 11s, we're going to erase 2 dots.
For example, in the first 11 we erase this dot and then this dot and in the second 11, we do the same thing
So now the left-hand side becomes (10 + 1i)(10 - 1i).
When we expand this out, we get 100 + 10i - 10i - i².
This simplifies to be 100 - i², which is equal to 100 - (-1),
which then becomes 101,
which is exactly equal to 100 + 1!.
The solution is complex, but the answer is quite real.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video. These math videos, which can be watched for free,
inspire and build confidence for people around the world, and they already have over a hundred million views.
Let's share the beauty of mathematics.
With your help we can 'math' the world a better place.
Please subscribe for free to get the newest videos, watch and share all of Mind Your Decisions videos...
...email me a puzzle or math topic presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com.
If you so choose, you can check out my books which are listed in the video description and you can support me on patreon to earn exclusive rewards.
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support.